hello and uh we are back with the
coverage of round one of the sink Phil
cup and we are joined in the studio by
very special guest Tony Rich the
technical director of the grand chest
tour and Tony welcome to the show thanks
Joy it's good to be
here in this studio we brought in the
big dog for the commentary Tony that we
needed to up our game the hard-hitting
analysis that's that's why you're the
pointy guy over there Peter I think he
needs to go up right
welcome Tony nice to have you in studio
it's good to be here tell us about
what's coming up sure I'm excited about
the 2024 Grand chest tour season uh
teaser we will be back in all of our
great countries and cities that we were
in in 2023 for Repeat Performance okay
the grand chest tour will kick off in
May next year just like it did in 2023
and we'll start our events in Poland
we'll continue on from there to Grand
chest tour uh in Romania that would be
the grand chest tour classic we continue
from there to Grand chestor Croatia and
then finally we finish up in St Louis
with the St Louis rapid and Blitz in
sinkfield cup in August so it's
definitely a very different uh time
schedule obviously we're in November
right now and uh the events have all got
squeezed together that's right yeah so
we're moving back to the the summertime
for singfield cup um you know it's
interesting the the grand chest circuit
being a a series of tournaments it's
great whenever we can get this in just a
few months 3 four 5 months something
like that the players enjoy the fact
that they can go from the first event to
the last event it's hard-hitting it's
fast they know what the standings are
and they know what's at stake so
bringing everything back to the summer I
think is really great for the grand
chest tour yeah and obviously this is
our tour but there's so many other
tournaments including the club has so
many events the classics and everything
else Tony you you I don't know how you
guys do it frankly sometimes you do too
much we direct about 25 major events a
year and major events are ones that are
fed rated tournaments that where Norms
are possible right so this would be the
five national championships the
singfield cup and St Louis rapid and
Blitz the Kiren cup four classic
tournaments a year for those very strong
Collegiate players and the folks
breaking through to that 2700 level Norm
tournaments for players just trying to
become Grand Masters it works out to on
average about once a month a little more
than that we'll have one or two
tournaments at the same time right well
you guys are hosting and then right
across the street you've got all the the
stuff that's happening at the World
Chess Hall of Fame from the exhibits to
the music and everything you just it
it's constant we're lucky to have such
great Partners at the hall of fame you
know the exhibits over there I always
came I came from a Chess World right so
I was the chess player and never the
chess historian the chess artist I
didn't appreciate that aspect of the
game and the Hall of Fame really has
changed that for me it it shows you the
cultural impact chess is made in pop
culture in commercials in comic books
even right all the way through Fine Art
you know chess and how it's used in in
media chess and how it's used in
commercials and television the Hall of
Fame teaches you why you should play
chess exactly yeah and what was exciting
schedule for 2024 which one are you
personally looking forward to seeing um
whichever one Magness plays and I'll say
it's always exciting whenever we get the
highest rated player competing in our
events right Tony I have to say for me
personally speaking when you have
audience and Spectators it's so much
more attractive personally now I
understand why we went to the model of
you know keeping the hall without the
spectators because as you see on screen
at the World Chess Hall of Fame uh this
the space is comfortable for the players
you had 100 Spectators and be a little
bit packed
uh don't you miss the spectators though
absolutely AER I am one of those
Spectators who loves to sit there and
watch them play their games I want to
see the Nuance of a player in in the
pressure they feel or maybe the
confidence that they feel me too so I
can tell you that the remodel of the
chess club is underway now okay uh we've
been on a delay unfortunately for the
past year or so construction has been
halted absolutely all of these hurdles
uh should finally be coming to an end we
have a closing date set in early
December and in theory that means we can
start driving nails into the walls
shortly after that so the hope is once
construction starts it'll take 12 months
for completion okay so in 2024 the
events for the St Louis chess club will
be at the World Chess Hall of Fame as
you saw earlier right um but we look
forward to 2025 bringing everybody back
to the club Tony thank you so much for
being in studio thank you for telling us
and I can't wait to have the spectators
uh allowed in again thank you so much my
pleasure thank much for joining us and
uh tell us about the results thus far uh